first scene I've ever done it's not
scripted so I'm telling myself in my
head who's my man who's my man who's
Waterson what am I I go well what am I
about I said I'm about my car yeah I go
well I'm in my 70 Chevelle I said I'm
about getting high I said well Slater's
riding shotgun he's got a dew bar rolled
up right I said I'm about rock and roll
there we go we got Ted Nugent strangle
holding the eight track and I hear
action
and so I look up and in my head I go
well the fourth thing I'm about
is chicks and that's what I'm about to
go pick up and in my mind I said well
you got three out of four
all right all right all right and that
was me confirming out loud the three
things I got and I'm gonna go get the
four